OK America, there's a phone number that you can call in Kansas, and when they pick up the phone, they say--.
好的，美国。在堪萨斯州有一个你可以拨打的电话号码，当他们接起电话时，他们会说——。
Good afternoon, Center for Army Lessons Learned. May I help you?
下午好，陆军经验教训中心。有什么可以帮您的吗？
The Center for Army Lessons Learned. The first time you hear that name, it's hard to believe that it's real, and not one of those places like the Hogwarts School, that it would be so amazing to believe that it existed. But of course, it never could exist.
陆军经验教训中心。第一次听到这个名字时，很难相信它是真的，而不是像霍格沃茨魔法学校那样的地方，很难相信它竟然真实存在。当然，它本不该存在。
I guess you would say we collect lessons learned.
我想你会说我们负责收集经验教训。
Colonel Steve Mains runs the center.
史蒂夫·梅恩斯上校负责管理该中心。
Lessons that the units are learning in combat, lessons that are being learned in training, and also in experimentation. And we are kind of the connective tissue, then, to distill those lessons, and then get them out to the people that need them; to transfer knowledge faster than our enemy.
部队在战斗中学习到的教训，在训练和实验中学习到的教训。我们就像是连接的组织，提炼这些教训，然后把它们传递给需要的人；比我们的敌人更快地传递知识。
It is a 200 person operation to do all this. And this is a pretty new thing for the Army. The center has only been around since the mid 1980s, and didn't really get cooking until the first Gulf War. One way they get their information, they embed researchers with units all over the world, including combat units in Iraq, for six months or a year at a time, to report from the field about the latest innovations-- what works, what doesn't work. And then, to get those lessons out, the  center puts out reports and handbooks. There's this massive website for soldiers to download all this stuff. And if that weren't enough, there's a reference desk.
这是一个由200人组成的机构来完成所有这些工作。这对陆军来说是一件相当新鲜的事情。该中心仅存在于20世纪80年代中期，直到第一次海湾战争才真正开始运转。他们获取信息的一种方式是，将研究人员嵌入世界各地的部队中，包括伊拉克的战斗部队，每次在那里待上六个月或一年，从现场报告最新的创新——什么有效，什么无效。然后，为了发布这些经验教训，中心会发布报告和手册。有一个庞大的网站供士兵下载所有这些资料。如果这还不够，还有一个咨询台。
This is a place where, if the soldier doesn't have the information, or the commander doesn't have the information, he can call my folks here and request the specific information that he needs. And then our guys will get it out to them, if they're deployed within 24 hours.
这是一个地方，如果士兵没有信息，或者指挥官没有信息，他可以打电话给我这里的人，请求他需要的具体信息。然后我们的人会在24小时内（如果他们已部署的话）将其发送给他们。
Right now, we're answering just about 500 warriors a month.
目前，我们每个月要为大约500名战士提供解答。
Craig Hayes runs the desk that answers these requests for information, which are almost all over email. He's officially a civilian, a retired lieutenant colonel, and a veteran of the current war in Iraq. He is the very first person who's ever had a full time job answering these inquiries.
克雷格·海耶斯负责管理这个回答这些信息请求的咨询台，这些请求几乎全是通过电子邮件发送的。他正式身份是平民，是一名退役中校，也是当前伊拉克战争的退伍军人。他是第一个全职负责回答这些咨询的人。
It's amazing what kind of questions the warriors will come up with. It could be current convoy operations, traffic control points. It could be how many spaces between letters on an official document. It could be the surge. So now we're getting more questions on what we got to do to deploy.
战士们提出的问题令人惊奇。可能是当前的护送行动、交通管制点。可能是官方文件中字母之间的空格数。可能是增兵问题。所以现在我们收到了更多关于我们需要做什么才能进行部署的问题。
What kind of insurgency tactics, training Iraqi police, getting Sunni and Shiite in your area to get along better. When it comes to a lot of these things, Colonel Mains says, the questions that the center gets pretty much amount to--.
什么样的反叛乱战术，训练伊拉克警察，让当地的逊尼派和什叶派相处得更好。谈到这些问题时，梅恩斯上校说，中心收到的问题基本上等同于——。
What's the latest? What's the state of the art? What has worked in the past, and what were the pitfalls?
最新情况是什么？目前最先进的技术是什么？过去有哪些成功的经验，又有哪些陷阱？
Colonel, what did we do in other wars?
上校，我们在其他战争中是怎么做的？
Well, it was a much more informal process. If you go back to World War II, Slam Marshall did a lot of studies, particularly in the Pacific, but there was a big delay. He went around, and he collected his information, and then he had to come back and compile it in a report. And then that report has got to be sent paper copy back out to the units that would need it.
嗯，那是一个非正式得多的过程。如果你回到二战，斯莱姆·马歇尔做了很多研究，特别是在太平洋地区，但有很大的延迟。他四处走动，收集信息，然后不得不回来编写报告。然后那份报告必须以纸质副本的形式寄回给需要它的部队。
I mean, this morning, I've already answered four or five questions already.
我的意思是，今天早上，我已经回答了四五个问题了。
This morning you've answered four or five questions already? What were those about?
今天早上你已经回答了四五个问题了？它们是关于什么的？
What's causing vehicles to roll over, I guess, was one.
我想，其中一个是关于导致车辆翻车的原因。
That's Lane Rolf, who works the reference desk answering questions. He says that back when he was in Baghdad as military police, he was a company commander, he could have used some of the information that he now gives out every day in his job, like how to recognize improvised explosive devices, IEDs, something his unit had to learn on the fly. Though other questions he gets, he never would have needed help with.
那是莱恩·罗尔夫，他在咨询台回答问题。他说，当他在巴格达担任宪兵时，他是一名连长，他本可以使用他现在每天工作时分发的一些信息，比如如何识别简易爆炸装置（IED），这是他的部队必须在现场即时学习的东西。虽然他收到的其他问题，他本来根本不需要帮助。
A friend of mine-- I'll also do a lot of informal questions. A friend of mine's over their right now in a unit. There are some MWR questions that we can answer just to help soldiers stay current over there.
我的一个朋友——我也会处理很多非正式的问题。我的一个朋友现在就在那边的一个部队里。有一些关于士气、福利和娱乐（MWR）的问题，我们可以回答，只是为了帮助那里的士兵保持与外界的联系。
What's MWR?
什么是MWR？
Morale, welfare, and recreation.
士气、福利和娱乐。
What did your friend want to know?
你朋友想知道什么？
He wanted to know how the Oklahoma Sooners did in the draft, and how the Big 12 is going to do this year in football. He wanted to know because he's out of touch.
他想知道俄克拉荷马大学速跑者队在选秀中的表现，以及大十二联盟今年的足球赛情况。他想知道，因为他与外界断了联系。
So that would be a morale question right there?
所以那是一个关于士气的问题？
Yes.
是的。
He remembers one email that he got from a military policeman, a young sergeant who was heading over to Iraq for the first time. He was worried because he had never had to lead a squad before. He wanted to know how to train them better so everybody would come back alive.
他记得他收到的一封来自宪兵的电子邮件，那是一名第一次前往伊拉克的年轻中士。他很担心，因为他以前从未领导过一个小队。他想知道如何更好地训练他们，这样每个人都能活着回来。
I called him right away, because we don't necessarily just have to respond by email. I said, hey Sergeant, there's a reason why you're a leader now. Don't doubt what you know, first of all. I need to know where you're going, and I can provide you with a whole bunch of information derived from last units coming back. And he said, holy cow sir, this is exactly what I need. This will help me sleep at night. I know that I'm going to help my guys. And that right there really touched my heart. And I had to go outside and have a cup of coffee. And like, you know what? This is exactly why I want this job. Every day I feel like I help another soldier. I fought to come over to get this job.
我立刻打电话给他，因为我们不一定非要通过电子邮件回复。我说，嘿，中士，你现在成为领导者是有原因的。首先，不要怀疑你所知道的东西。我需要知道你要去哪里，我可以为你提供大量从最近回来的部队那里得到的经验教训。他说，天哪，长官，这正是他所需要的。这会帮助我在晚上睡个好觉。我知道我会帮助我的部下。那一点真的触动了我的心。我不得不走出去喝了杯咖啡。就觉得，你知道吗？这就是我想要这份工作的原因。每天我都觉得我在帮助另一名士兵。我争取到了这份工作。
You did?
你争取到了？
There was a lot of other people fighting for this job.
有很多人在争取这份工作。
Talking to guys at the Center for Army Lessons Learned, it's hard not to feel kind of hopeful. It's the US Army at its best: smart, practical, can-do. And today on our show, during this war in Iraq that drags out for month after month, longer than our involvement in World War II, longer than the Civil War, we wanted to feel a little hopeful for a change, and talk about what's been learned, and try to understand why there's certain lessons that  we're taking so long to learn. From Chicago Public Radio, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio international. I'm Ira Glass.
与陆军经验教训中心的人交谈，很难不感到一种希望。这是美国陆军最好的一面：聪明、务实、能干。今天在我们的节目中，在这场伊拉克战争拖延了几个月又几个月，比我们参与二战的时间更长，比内战时间更长的情况下，我们想换个心情，感受一点希望，谈谈学到了什么，并试图理解为什么有些经验教训我们要花那么长时间才能学会。来自芝加哥公共广播电台，这是《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台分发。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Our show today for this Memorial Day weekend, The Center For Lessons Learned. Our show in three acts, including Scott Carrier in Salt Lake City on lessons for civilians in this war. And Washington Post reporter Thomas Ricks, the author of Fiasco , in Baghdad, who says there's a whole different sensibility in the air in the Green Zone these days, where Americans seem to have learned some lessons. Stay with us.
我们今天的阵亡将士纪念日周末节目是《经验教训中心》。我们的节目分三幕，包括在盐湖城的斯科特·卡里尔关于这场战争中平民的教训。以及目前在巴格达的《华盛顿邮报》记者、著作《惨败》的作者托马斯·里克斯，他说如今绿区的空气中弥漫着一种完全不同的感觉，美国人似乎已经吸取了一些教训。请继续收听。
Act one, Cassandra. Everybody knows that we occupied Germany after World War II, but you might not know that we occupied part of Germany after World War I. And two interesting things happened. One, it did not go so well. And two, the soldiers involved took very good notes. In fact, there's a four volume report on that occupation, hand typed, complete with typos, in which one Colonel Erwin L. Hunt summed up what happened this way: quote, "The American army of occupation lacked both the training and organization to guide the destinies of the nearly 1 million civilians, whom the fortunes of war had placed under its temporary sovereignty."
第一幕，卡珊德拉。大家都知道二战后我们占领了德国，但你可能不知道一战后我们也占领了德国的一部分。发生了两件有趣的事情。第一，过程并不太顺利。第二，参与的士兵做了非常好的记录。事实上，有一份关于那次占领的四卷本报告，手工打字，连拼写错误都保留了下来，其中欧文·L·亨特上校总结了发生的事情，引文如下：“美国占领军既缺乏训练，也缺乏组织，无法引导被战争命运置于其临时主权之下的近100万平民的命运。”
So when World War II happened, military planners did not want to botch another occupation in the same exact country, and they returned to this report to understand what went wrong. And the occupation after World War II went very differently, not only the Marshall Plan for the rebuilding of Europe, but there was an entire infrastructure of schools, and classes, and training devoted to getting Americans, American military, prepared to occupy and rebuild another country. Which is to say, we learned from our mistake. We figured out how to occupy and rebuild a country after a war. Well, Nancy Updike has this story about one man's quest to make America remember that particular lesson.
所以当二战发生时，军事规划者不想在同一个国家再次搞砸另一次占领，他们回到这份报告中去了解出了什么问题。二战后的占领过程大不相同，不仅有了重建欧洲的马歇尔计划，而且还有整个学校、课程和训练的基础设施，致力于让美国人、美国军队做好准备去占领和重建另一个国家。也就是说，我们从错误中吸取了教训。我们弄清楚了如何在战后占领和重建一个国家。南希·厄普代克带来了关于一个人追求让美国记住那个特定教训的故事。
I want to read to you from page 42 of this booklet that came out in January of 2003. That's two months before we invaded Iraq. Here's what it says. "The possibility of the United States winning the war and losing the peace in Iraq is real and serious. Thinking about the war now and the occupation later is not an acceptable solution. Without an overwhelming effort to prepare for occupation, the United States may find itself in a radically different world over the next few years, a world in which the threat of Saddam Hussein seems like a pale shadow, of new problems of America's own making."
我想读给你们听这本小册子的第42页，它出版于2003年1月。那是在我们入侵伊拉克前两个月。上面是这样写的。“美国在伊拉克赢得战争却输掉和平的可能性是真实且严重的。现在只考虑战争，以后再考虑占领，并不是一个可接受的解决方案。如果没有压倒性的努力为占领做准备，美国可能会在未来几年发现自己处于一个截然不同的世界中，在这个世界里，萨达姆·侯赛因的威胁看起来就像美国自己制造的新问题的一个苍白阴影。”
That paragraph is only one of this report's many predictions, observations, and warnings that have made a guy named Conrad Crane famous in certain circles as a man who should have been listened to. The report is called "Reconstructing Iraq." It was commissioned by the Army in the run-up to the Iraq War. They wanted a guide for what to do after the fighting ended, how to occupy, stabilize, and reconstruct a country, based on previous wars, and on Iraq's specific challenges. And the booklet ends with a detailed nine page chart listing what would need to get done, who should do it, everything from securing the borders, the banking system, the museums, to dealing with sewage and medical waste.
那段话只是这份报告的众多预测、观察和警告之一，这些内容使一个名叫康拉德·克雷恩的人在某些圈子里变得出名，被视为一个本应被倾听的人。这份报告名为《重建伊拉克》。它是由陆军在伊拉克战争筹备期间委托编写的。他们想要一份关于战斗结束后该做什么的指南，如何基于以往的战争和伊拉克面临的具体挑战，来占领、稳定和重建一个国家。小册子以一份详细的九页图表结束，列出了需要完成的事情，谁应该去做，从确保边境、银行系统、博物馆的安全，到处理污水和医疗废物，应有尽有。
Crane co-wrote the booklet. He's a historian, a 26 year Army veteran, and director of the Army's archives at the US Army War College, the Military History Institute. And seven years ago, in 2000, before he became known for having written this booklet, Crane was just one more historian with pale hair, glasses, and a head full of ideas, and a problem that is not uncommon among idea people.
克雷恩是这本小册子的合著者。他是一名历史学家，26年的陆军老兵，也是美国陆军战争学院军事历史研究所美国陆军档案的负责人。七年前，即2000年，在他因为编写这本小册子而闻名之前，克雷恩只是另一个有着苍白头发、戴着眼镜、脑子里装满想法的历史学家，而且有一个在想法多的人群中并不罕见的问题。
People would kind of treat me like a humorous eccentric, like a salesman for some commodity that they didn't really want.
人们会把我当作一个有趣的怪人，就像是一个他们并不真正想要的商品的推销员。
The unwanted commodity that Crane was pushing was an idea he'd been trying to get the military to take seriously for years. It started like this. Crane had been studying the aftermath of US military involvements big and small, going back more than 100 years. Nation building in Germany and Japan, the toppling of Noriega in Panama, our long occupation of the Philippines, humanitarian and peacekeeping efforts in Haiti, Bosnia, Somalia, even reconstruction efforts in the South after the Civil War. And what Crane found was that after major combat ends, there are always a whole bunch of unglamorous, bigger than expected, absolutely crucial tasks that the military is often the only one around to do; tasks that can mean the difference between stability and chaos. And Crane's idea was this: that the military needed to become much better prepared to take on everything that happens after major combat ends in a given war or conflict, the so-called--.
克雷恩推销的不想要的商品是一个他多年来一直试图让军方认真对待的想法。它是这样开始的。克雷恩一直在研究美国军事介入（无论大小）的后果，可以追溯到100多年前。在德国和日本的国家建设，在巴拿马推翻诺列加，我们在菲律宾的长期占领，在海地、波斯尼亚、索马里的维和与人道主义努力，甚至南北战争后南方的重建努力。克雷恩发现，在大规模战斗结束后，总有一堆不光彩、比预期规模大、绝对关键的任务，通常只有军方在场来做；这些任务可能意味着稳定与混乱之间的区别。克雷恩的想法是：军方需要做好更充分的准备，以承担在特定的战争或冲突中大规模战斗结束后所发生的一切，所谓的——。
Messy aftermath. Post-conflict operations, the stability operations, reconstructions, occupations. The point was that the wars are won in the way that peace is established, really.
混乱的余波。冲突后行动，稳定行动，重建，占领。关键在于，战争的胜负确实取决于和平建立的方式。
To say that now, wars are won or lost in the way that peace is established, is to state the obvious. We wouldn't still be in Iraq or Afghanistan if it weren't true. But before Iraq and Afghanistan, before 9/11, Crane's notion that the military should devote a lot more thought, money, and manpower to post-war planning was an idea that could not get traction. It was one small, unpopular corner of the never-ending debate about military strategy and doctrine.
现在说战争的胜负取决于和平建立的方式，简直是老生常谈。如果这不是事实，我们现在就不会还在伊拉克或阿富汗了。但在伊拉克和阿富汗战争之前，在9·11之前，克雷恩关于军方应该投入更多思考、资金和人力进行战后规划的观点，是一个无法引起重视的想法。它是关于军事战略和学说的无休止争论中一个微小、不受欢迎的角落。
After we invaded two countries and toppled two governments, suddenly rebuilding and stabilizing a postwar country became arguably the most urgent job, not just for our national security, but also for the security of large chunks of the rest of the world. But back in the fall of 2002, a half year before the invasion of Iraq, Crane and a Middle East expert named Andrew Terrill started cranking out that booklet I read from earlier, "Reconstructing Iraq." They did it in three months, working like crazy, and getting input from other civilian and military experts from the Department of Defense, the State Department, the Joint Forces Command, the Army.
在我们入侵了两个国家并推翻了两个政府之后，重建和稳定战后国家突然成为可以说最紧迫的工作，不仅对我们的国家安全，而且对世界其他大片地区的安全也是如此。但在2002年秋天，即入侵伊拉克前半年前，克雷恩和一位名叫安德鲁·特里尔的中东专家开始赶制我之前读过的那本小册子——《重建伊拉克》。他们花了三个月时间，疯狂工作，并从国防部、国务院、联合部队司令部和陆军的其他平民和军事专家那里获得了投入。
We had a great sense of urgency. We wanted to get it out as fast as we could. We expected it was going to have a major impact. We knew the Army staff at the time was interested in it. We were sending stuff constantly to the planners in the theater. And we got some good input from the planners in the theater as well. It was only later, a few months we get in the middle of 2003 where we started to get a sense that, boy, I wish we'd been listened to more than we were.
我们有极强的紧迫感。我们想尽可能快地把它发布出去。我们预计它会产生重大影响。我们知道当时的陆军参谋部对它很感兴趣。我们不断地把东西发给战区的规划者。我们也从战区的规划者那里得到了一些很好的建议。只是后来，在2003年中期，当我们开始感觉到时，天哪，我真希望我们能比实际情况受到更多的倾听。
Reading this booklet four years into the war, it feels like Crane and Terrill came from the future and traveled back in time to January, 2003 to try and warn us. Page 24, "Even under free elections, differences within Iraqi society may be further exacerbated." Page 34, "Unlike a variety of other dictatorships, many Iraqi citizens have access to firearms. These weapons can become a problem following the war." Page 32, "To tear apart the Iraqi army in the war's aftermath could lead to the destruction of one of the only forces for unity within the society. Breaking up large elements of the army also raises the possibility that demobilized soldiers could affiliate with ethnic or tribal militias."
在战争进行了四年后阅读这本小册子，感觉就像克雷恩和特里尔是从未来穿越回了2003年1月，试图警告我们。第24页，“即使在自由选举下，伊拉克社会内部的分歧可能会进一步加剧。”第34页，“与其他各种独裁政权不同，许多伊拉克公民可以获得枪支。这些武器在战后可能会成为一个问题。”第32页，“在战争结束后拆散伊拉克军队可能导致社会内部唯一的一支统一力量被摧毁。解散军队的大部分要素也增加了复员士兵可能加入种族或部落民兵的可能性。”
Page 40, "If the United States assumes control of Iraq, it will assume control of a badly battered economy." Page 38, "After the first year, the possibility of a serious uprising may increase, should severe disillusionment set in, and Iraqis begin to draw parallels between US actions and historical examples of Western imperialism." Page 35, "Having entered into Iraq, the United States will find itself unable to leave rapidly, despite the many pressures to do so."
第40页，“如果美国接管伊拉克，它将接管一个遭受严重破坏的经济。”第38页，“第一年后，如果出现严重的幻灭，且伊拉克人开始将美国的行为与西方帝国主义的历史例子进行比较，发生严重起义的可能性可能会增加。”第35页，“一旦进入伊拉克，美国将发现自己无法迅速离开，尽管面临着多重压力。”
So if we had this booklet, why weren't we better prepared for what to do after President Bush declared--.
那么，如果我们有这本小册子，为什么我们在布什总统宣布——之后没有做好更好的准备来应对呢？
Major combat operations in Iraq have ended. In the battle of Iraq, the United States and our allies have prevailed. [APPLAUSE]
伊拉克的主要战斗行动已经结束。在伊拉克战役中，美国和我们的盟友取得了胜利。[掌声]
Well, one thing that Crane found about previous wars is that the Pentagon, that is the military and its civilian leadership, has a sort of amnesia about these post-conflict stability operations. The military doesn't like to do them, so they often don't prepare to do them, or they underprepare. The Gulf War is a perfect example. We were so focused on winning the war, that we got surprised at the end of the war by how much there was to do in Kuwait. And believe it or not, there was a lot to do. According to the Army, tiny Kuwait ended up being the largest civil military reconstruction effort the US had undertaken since World War II.
嗯，克雷恩关于以前战争发现的一件事是，五角大楼，即军方及其文职领导层，对这些冲突后的稳定行动有一种健忘症。军方不喜欢做这些事情，所以他们往往不准备做，或者准备不足。海湾战争就是一个完美的例子。我们太专注于赢得战争，以至于我们在战争结束时对科威特有这么多工作要做感到惊讶。信不信由你，有很多工作要做。据陆军称，小小的科威特最终成为美国自二战以来所承担的最大规模的军民重建努力。
But in the run-up to the war, Crane found, all those post-conflict tasks were treated, as one US commander put it, like quote, "a dripping bag of manure."
但克雷恩发现，在战争筹备期间，所有这些冲突后的任务都被对待，正如一位美国指挥官所说，就像“一袋滴水的肥料”。
That's from John Yeosock, who commanded the 3rd Army in the first Gulf War. And he talked about his experiences going into his staff when they get ready to go on the operation, he asked questions about how are we taking care of prisoners of war? How are we taking care of refugees? And people hadn't kind of thought about that stuff. And he said, it was a dripping bag of manure that nobody wanted to handle. Because the assumption was somebody else was going to do this. The UN or--
这句话来自在第一次海湾战争中指挥第三集团军的约翰·耶索克。他谈到了他在准备行动时进入参谋部时的经历，他问关于我们如何照顾战俘？我们如何照顾难民？人们并没有考虑过这些事情。他说，这是一袋没人想处理的滴水的肥料。因为假设是别人会做这件事。联合国或者——
This is somebody else's bag of manure?
这是别人的肥料袋吗？
That's right. The UN's going to take care of this, or the Iraqis themselves are. Or the Red Cross will do it. But he said, no, we've got to be prepared to do this.
没错。联合国会处理这件事，或者伊拉克人自己会处理。或者红十字会会做。但他说了，不，我们必须准备好做这些事。
I'm John Yeosock. I commanded the US, UK, and French Army ground forces during Desert Shield and Desert Storm. I've been retired now for a dozen years. And probably my worst feelings about that whole war is that so many things went so well, so quickly. Because no one was left with an understanding of really what it takes to get it done.
我是约翰·耶索克。我在“沙漠盾牌”和“沙漠风暴”行动期间指挥了美国、英国和法国的陆军地面部队。我已经退休十二年了。我对那场战争最糟糕的感觉可能是，太多的事情进展得太顺利、太快了。因为没有人理解真正完成工作需要什么。
Getting it done for Lieutenant General Yeosock did not just mean coordinating battles. No, after this short, seemingly easy war was officially over, Kuwait was in shambles. The Kuwaiti government and a lot of its workforce had fled. Iraq had been occupying the country for months. There were landmines to clear, a port to dredge, oil wells on fire, and a lot of just plain destruction of buildings and infrastructure, plus tens of thousands of Iraqi refugees and prisoners of war. Not to mention all the things we're now familiar with, because they didn't get done in the Iraq War: getting electricity and water back to normal, policing the streets, a thousand issues.
对于耶索克中将来说，完成工作不仅仅意味着协调战斗。不，在这场短暂、看似轻松的战争正式结束后，科威特已是一片混乱。科威特政府和其许多劳动力已经逃离。伊拉克已经占领该国数月。有地雷需要清除，港口需要疏浚，油井在燃烧，还有许多纯粹的建筑物和基础设施的破坏，加上成千上万的伊拉克难民和战俘。更不用说我们现在熟悉的所有事情，因为它们在伊拉克战争中没有完成：恢复电力和水的供应，街道治安，一千个问题。
Made my head hurt always, because I could not think of everything. You live your whole life learning how to dominate an enemy, and all that kind of stuff. Who likes to be in charge of ensuring that diapers are available for these displaced civilians? But as a human being, you understand that, well by golly, you just do it.
这总是让我的头很痛，因为我无法想到所有事情。你一生都在学习如何统治敌人，以及所有那一类的事情。谁喜欢负责确保为这些流离失所的平民提供尿布？但作为一个人类，你明白，天哪，你必须做这件事。
Of course, civilian agencies do a lot of this postwar work too. But sometimes it's not safe for large numbers of civilians to come in, even after major combat is over. Remember the UN compound getting bombed in Iraq? The military is used to operating in the midst of chaos, so they end up handling a lot of nonmilitary tasks when major combat ends, whether they prepare for them or not. After the first Gulf War, which we won in 100 hours on the ground, the Department of Defense spent a year rebuilding Kuwait.
当然，平民机构也做很多这种战后工作。但有时让大量平民进入并不安全，即使在大规模战斗结束后也是如此。还记得在伊拉克被炸毁的联合国大院吗？军方习惯于在混乱中运作，所以当大规模战斗结束后，他们最终会处理许多非军事任务，无论他们是否为此做好了准备。在第一次海湾战争（我们在地面上用了100小时获胜）之后，国防部花了一年时间重建科威特。
Desert Storm was such an overwhelming success, in terms of measures like time, casualties, et cetera, that because so many of these things went so smoothly, I think just too many people didn't understand that things like this had to be done. It was probably one of the worst lessons we took away.
沙漠风暴行动在时间、伤亡率等方面取得了巨大的成功，因为这么多事情进展得如此顺利，我认为太多人没有理解必须做这样的事情。这可能是我们吸取的最糟糕的教训之一。
It looks so easy on the surface.
表面看起来太容易了。
Here's Crane again, talking about the first Gulf War.
这是克雷恩再次谈论第一次海湾战争。
The stuff that happened afterwards just was not-- didn't get any notice. And it wasn't studied and it should have been.
之后发生的事情根本没有——没有得到任何注意。它没有被研究，而本应被研究的。
There's a military saying that defeat is an army's best teacher. An unspoken corollary is that success is often not the best teacher. And because the aftermath of the first Gulf War wasn't studied and absorbed, the lesson that many in the military and civilian leadership took away from that war is that if we wanted to, we could do a better kind of war, quick and decisive. That's what the current war in Iraq was supposed to be, as was Afghanistan. It was part of the revolution former Defense Secretary Donald Rumsfeld was pushing in the Pentagon: fewer soldiers, more high tech gear, no nation building.
有一句军事格言说，失败是军队最好的老师。一个未言明的必然结果是，成功往往不是最好的老师。由于第一次海湾战争的余波没有被研究和吸收，许多军方和文职领导层从那场战争中吸取的教训是，如果我们愿意，我们可以进行一种更好的战争，快速且具有决定性。这就是当前伊拉克战争本应有的样子，阿富汗也是如此。这是前国防部长唐纳德·拉姆斯费尔德在五角大楼推动的变革的一部分：更少的士兵，更多的高科技装备，不进行国家建设。
It seems crazy to think about this now, but after Baghdad fell, the plan was to get most of our troops out of Iraq by the end of 2003. Crane is one of dozens of people inside and outside the military who tried to push for more troops for Iraq, not because we'd need them to win the war, but because we wouldn't be able to stabilize the country without them.
现在想起来似乎很疯狂，但在巴格达陷落后，计划是在2003年底前将我们的大部分军队撤出伊拉克。克雷恩是军内外几十个试图推动向伊拉克增兵的人之一，不是因为我们需要他们来赢得战争，而是因为如果没有他们，我们将无法稳定该国。
So whatever happened to Crane and Terrill's booklet, the one that foresaw a lot of the problems we've had in Iraq, and offered a plan for how to prevent them?
那么克雷恩和特里尔的小册子到底发生了什么？那本预见了我们在伊拉克遇到的大部分问题，并提供了如何防止它们计划的小册子？
We got our study out in the end of January. And one of the ironies of it is almost exactly the time we finished the study, is the time that the-- the main reason we had done the study kind of disappeared.
我们在1月底拿出了我们的研究报告。讽刺的是，在我们完成研究的时候，我们做这项研究的主要原因也消失了。
On January 20, 2003, two months before the invasion, the White House decided to switch gears. The Army would not take charge of the occupation after the war. Instead, that would be done by a newly formed civilian body, what would later become the Coalition Provisional Authority. And with that announcement, Crane and Terrill's booklet, months of work, was dropped from the planning process for the war. And they weren't the only ones. In the months leading up to the invasion, other detailed plans and warnings about the coming occupation were also being ignored or shut out, including efforts by the State Department, the US Agency for International Development, the Marine Corps, the National Defense University, the Rand Corporation, the Council on Foreign Relations.
2003年1月20日，即入侵前两个月，白宫决定换挡。战后陆军将不再负责占领。相反，那将由一个新成立的文职机构来完成，也就是后来成为“联盟驻伊拉克临时管理当局”的机构。随着那一宣布，克雷恩和特里尔的小册子（数月的工作）被从战争规划过程中剔除。他们并不是唯一的人。在入侵前的几个月里，其他关于即将到来的占领的详细计划和警告也被忽视或排斥，包括国务院、美国国际开发署、海军陆战队、国防大学、兰德公司、对外关系委员会的努力。
One of the tragedies of Iraq is that so many people did try to plan for the post-major combat phase. But the civilian leadership at the Pentagon resisted suggestions that the occupation might be long and complicated and require nation building. So almost none of that planning, not Crane and Terrill's, not any of the others, was put into action when it might have mattered.
伊拉克的悲剧之一是，许多人确实试图为大规模战斗后的阶段进行规划。但五角大楼的文职领导层抵制了关于占领可能是漫长而复杂且需要国家建设的建议。因此，几乎没有任何规划（无论是克雷恩和特里尔的，还是其他任何人的）在可能重要的时候被付诸实践。
Anything we've worked on, the main payback is going to be that it's going to be valuable to people in the field, and we're going to save lives. And I think we really felt that about the study, that's this was something that people in important places are going to be able to make real use of this.
我们所做的一切工作，主要的回报将是它对战场上的人有价值，我们将拯救生命。我认为我们对这项研究确实有这种感觉，这是重要位置上的人能够真正利用的东西。
Instead of seeing people in important places make use of his research, Crane had the opposite experience. He had to watch while one thing after another that he and Terrill had hoped to prevent came to pass. I kept asking him, didn't that drive you crazy? But he wouldn't take the bait. He's a former soldier and historian, not much given to public acts of gloating or hand wringing. The one time he did show real frustration, in the form of a sharp sigh, was when I asked him about the moment in 2003 when he'd heard the Iraqi army had been disbanded, something he and Terrill had strongly warned against in the booklet, saying that sending home men with guns was a bad idea, that they might turn the guns on us. So here comes that sigh.
克雷恩不仅没有看到重要位置上的人利用他的研究，反而经历了相反的情况。他不得不看着他与特里尔曾希望防止的一件事接连发生。我一直在问他，这难道没有让你发疯吗？但他没有上当。他是一名退伍军人和历史学家，不太倾向于公开幸灾乐祸或忧心忡忡。他唯一一次表现出真正的沮丧（以一声尖锐的叹息的形式）是在我问他2003年听到伊拉克军队已被解散的那一刻时，他和特里尔在小册子中曾强烈反对这一点，说遣散带枪的人是一个坏主意，他们可能会把枪口对准我们。所以那声叹息来了。
I had [SIGH]-- I was actually in communication by email with a couple of colonels who were working on how to kind of reform the Iraqi army. And I got to admit that I was really surprised, as were these colonels, shocked is probably too mild a term. Basically, I read it in the newspaper like everybody else. I was here at the War College, just reading the paper, and boom, there it was. And many people have pointed to that as maybe the greatest single mistake in our post-major combat operations actions. But we just had no inroads into the decision making process. You look at it with disappointment. You wish it'd gone different. And you hope that it was the right decision.
我曾[叹息]——我实际上通过电子邮件与几位正在研究如何以某种方式改革伊拉克军队的上校进行了交流。我必须承认，我真的感到惊讶，正如这些上校一样，震惊这个词可能太温和了。基本上，我像其他人一样从报纸上读到了它。我当时在战争学院，只是在看报纸，砰，就在那里了。许多人指出，这可能是我们冲突后行动中可能犯下的最大单一错误。但我们在决策过程中根本没有途径。你带着失望看着它。你希望它会有所不同。并且你希望这是一个正确的决定。
You hope to be wrong?
你希望自己是错的？
The way I explain to people when they say, well gee, how come they didn't listen to you? There are a lot of competing truths out there. I understand why very high level decision makers went the route they did, based on other truths. We have a very pessimistic view of Iraq, which in the end, I think turned out to be the right one. But we're just a bunch of observers at the Army War College. We did not have the prestige some of the other agencies had that were producing much more rosy scenarios of what was going to happen. But we did all we could do. We did more than we could do, if you look at some of the back channel routes we took to send this thing around.
我向那些问我“天哪，他们为什么不听你的？”的人解释的方式是：外面有很多相互竞争的事实。我理解为什么非常高级的决策者基于其他事实走了他们走的那条路。我们对伊拉克有着非常悲观的看法，我认为最终证明是正确的。但我们只是陆军战争学院的一群观察者。我们没有其他机构所拥有的威望，那些机构正在为将会发生什么制造更乐观的情景。但我们尽了我们所能做的一切。如果我们看看我们用来分发这份东西的一些后门渠道，我们甚至做了我们所能做的更多。
I read the report all in one sitting, and I was preparing to come over to Iraq. In fact, I was frustrated in my inability to get over here sooner.
我一口气读完了这份报告，我正准备前往伊拉克。事实上，我对自己无法早点过去感到沮丧。
Colonel H.R. McMaster was one of the people Crane gave the booklet to on his own initiative, through back channels. He got it to him in April, 2003, one month into the war. McMaster went on to pull off one of the astounding feats of the war. He figured out a strategy in a place called Tal Afar to do what we've been finding mostly impossible elsewhere in Iraq: defeating a fierce insurgency. I called him in Baghdad.
H.R.麦克马斯特上校是克雷恩主动通过后门渠道把小册子交给的人之一。他在2003年4月（战争开始一个月后）把它交给了他。麦克马斯特后来完成了战争中最令人震惊的壮举之一。他在一个叫塔拉法尔的地方制定了一个策略，做了我们在伊拉克其他地方发现几乎不可能的事情：击败了一场猛烈的叛乱。我打电话给巴格达的他。
Doctor Crane said that you told him you handed out the booklet when you got to Iraq. You handed out his booklet like Hari Krishna literature. Is that true?
克雷恩博士说你告诉他，当你到达伊拉克时，你分发了那本小册子。你像发放“哈瑞奎师那”传单一样发放他的小册子。这是真的吗？
Yes, it is true. Well, I had an in with Conrad Crane, so I asked him to send me a box of them, essentially, and loaded up every spare space in my luggage with the published monograph.
是的，这是真的。嗯，我和康拉德·克雷恩有联系，所以我请求他基本上寄给我一箱，把我的行李箱里的每一个空余空间都装满了这本已出版的专著。
About how many?
大概有多少？
Gosh, I think about 50.
天哪，我想大约50本。
50?
50本？
Right. And then Doctor Crane sent me some more also, once I had a mailing address where I was based in [? Gutter ?] at the time.
没错。然后当我有了当时我所在的（？）的邮寄地址后，克雷恩博士又给我寄了一些。
I don't even know the highest ranking person who read this. I mean, without naming any names, how high up were you able to get this booklet?
我甚至不知道阅读这个的最高级别的人是谁。我的意思是，在不透露任何名字的情况下，你能够把这本小册子送到多高的级别？
I probably can't-- it probably just wouldn't be appropriate for me to answer that.
我可能不能——我回答这个问题可能不太合适。
Right. As things were unfolding, and you had this booklet, this information on your mind, did you wish that more people had read it?
好吧。随着事情的发展，你脑子里有了这本小册子和这些信息，你是否希望更多的人读过它？
Gosh, I probably shouldn't comment on that one too much either.
天哪，我可能也不应该过多地评论那个。
These days, McMaster splits his time between a London think tank and Iraq, where he's part of the team assembled by the top commander in Iraq, General David Petraeus, to redesign US strategy in the country. But when McMaster first arrived in Baghdad, Crane and Terrill's booklet helped him grasp the scope of what he was facing. And then, like Crane had done, he went on a history binge.
这些天，麦克马斯特的时间在伦敦的一家智库和伊拉克之间分配，在那里他是伊拉克最高指挥官戴维·彼得雷乌斯将军组建的重塑美国在该国战略团队的一员。但当麦克马斯特刚抵达巴格达时，克雷恩和特里尔的小册子帮助他掌握了他所面临的情况的广度。然后，像克雷恩所做的那样，他开始狂看历史书。
A scholar at West Point went to the library at Columbia University, and pulled out a lot of books that were published by the British in the 1920s, photocopied the pages, scanned them in, and sent them to us on email.
西点军校的一位学者去了哥伦比亚大学的图书馆，翻出了许多英国人在20世纪20年代出版的书籍，复印了这些页面，扫描了它们，并通过电子邮件发送给了我们。
The pages had a breakdown of the tribes in the area where he and his soldiers were fighting. He also brought in an officer with a degree in Middle East history to serve with his regiment for two months. He reached out to other scholars, talked to Iraqis, all of which seems smart and straightforward. Why not look back and learn? The way McMaster and Crane saw it, we were facing tasks in Iraq we had faced before: counterinsurgency, stabilization and reconstruction. We knew how to do these things. But until well into the Iraq war, looking back was out of fashion among the people running the Pentagon. All through the 1990s and right up through 2003, the Defense Department was so focused on propelling itself into the future, that in the process, lessons from the past got ignored, and some tried and true, old school, boots on the ground soldiering just got eliminated.
这些页面上分解了他和他的士兵正在战斗地区的部落。他还带了一位拥有中东历史学位的军官与他的团一起服役了两个月。他联系了其他学者，与伊拉克人交谈，所有这些看起来都很聪明和直截了当。为什么不回顾过去学习呢？按照麦克马斯特和克雷恩的看法，我们在伊拉克面临着我们以前曾面临的任务：反叛乱、稳定和重建。我们知道如何做这些事情。但在伊拉克战争进行到很久之后，回顾过去在五角大楼的掌权者中并不流行。在整个20世纪90年代一直到2003年，国防部太专注于把自己推向未来，以至于在这个过程中，来自过去的教训被忽视了，一些经过实践检验的、老派的、脚踏实地的士兵技能被淘汰了。
We wrote out of our doctrine in the 1990s reconnaissance, finding out about the enemy, discovering the intentions of the enemy through questioning the population, through forcing the enemy to react with a reconnaissance force that could also fight for information. We also wrote out security operations, because we decided that we're not going to be surprised anymore. And this was a time where many people were sort of filled with a hubris about American technological superiority.
我们在20世纪90年代从我们的学说中删除了侦察，通过询问民众、通过迫使敌人用侦察部队（该部队也能为了信息而战）做出反应来发现关于敌人的情况，发现敌人的意图。我们也删除了安全行动，因为我们决定我们不再会感到惊讶。那是一个许多人对美国技术优势充满傲慢的时期。
There are two faith based arguments out there.
外面有两种基于信仰的论点。
Here's Crane again.
这是克雷恩再次谈到。
The one is that, I guess you'd call it the historians who say that nothing is new. Everything is based in the past, and if you understand the past, then you're prepared for the future. Then there's the, I guess you'd call them the technocrats, who say no, no, no, technology has changed everything. It's all brand new. The past is irrelevant. And it's always been a problem for any generals trying to predict what the future's going to be like, how much is new and how much is old? Nobody ever gets it right. Sir Michael Howard, the famous British military historian, he says nobody ever gets it right. The question is, how can you make sure that you're not so wrong that you can't make up for your mistakes?
一个是，我想你会称之为历史学家的人，他们说没有什么新鲜事。一切都植根于过去，如果你了解过去，那么你就会为未来做好准备。然后是，我想你会称之为技术官僚的人，他们说不，不，不，技术已经改变了一切。一切都是全新的。过去是无关紧要的。对于任何试图预测未来会是什么样的将军来说，这始终是一个问题，多少是新的，多少是旧的？没有人能做对。著名的英国军事历史学家迈克尔·霍华德爵士说，没有人能做对。问题是，你怎么能确保你不会错得离谱，以至于无法弥补你的错误？
You were saying before that in all of the competing truths and reports that were circulating before the war started, that you guys somehow didn't have as much muscle or prestige as other reports or truths that were circulating. Do you feel like the fact that you were so prescient in this report, do you feel like you have a little more muscle now? That people will listen to you?
你之前说过，在战争开始前流传的所有相互竞争的事实和报告中，你们似乎没有像流传的其他报告或事实那样拥有那么多的力量或威望。你是否觉得因为你在这份报告中如此有先见之明，你现在觉得有一点更多的力量了？人们会听你的吗？
I get invited a lot more conferences, to give a lot more presentations.
我被邀请参加更多的会议，做更多的演讲。
That sounds like a punishment.
那听起来像是一种惩罚。
Not really.  Andy Terrill was one of the people working with the Iraq Study Group. I've been asked to do a lot of work with people on developing scenarios, stability ops. Got drawn into the development of counterinsurgency doctrine for the Army and the Marine Corps. Everybody is thinking about this stuff now. It's very encouraging. But the question I get every time I do a presentation on counterinsurgency, and this new impetus on irregular warfare, and all these things we've talked about is, after Iraq, will we still be interested in it? Or is there are going to be this reaction again, like post-Vietnam, where we're all going to try to pull back in our shell?
不完全是。安迪·特里尔是与伊拉克研究小组合作的人之一。我被要求与人们一起在制定情景、稳定行动方面做大量工作。被拉入了为陆军和海军陆战队制定反叛乱学说的过程中。每个人现在都在思考这些事情。这是非常令人鼓舞的。但每当我做关于反叛乱的演讲，以及这种对非正规战争的新推动，以及所有我们讨论过的事情时，我收到的问题是，伊拉克之后，我们还会对它感兴趣吗？还是会再次出现这种反应，就像越战后一样，我们将试图缩回我们的壳里？
What do you think?
你怎么看？
I think that the best answer to that was one that was given by David Kilcullen.
我认为最好的答案是戴维·基尔库伦给出的那个。
He's a counterinsurgency expert who's now advising Petraeus.
他是现在为彼得雷乌斯提供建议的反叛乱专家。
That's the one. And he said basically, you know, our enemies are going to make us fight these kind of wars until we get them right. And that's the future we face; these very messy wars that play to our weaknesses, not to our strengths. I don't think we're going to be able to pull back and ignore these kind of things.
就是他。他基本上说，你知道，我们的敌人会迫使我们进行这种战争，直到我们弄清楚它们。这就是我们面临的未来；这些非常混乱的战争，利用我们的弱点，而不是我们的优势。我不认为我们将能够缩回并忽视这些事情。
That story from Nancy Updike, one of the producers of our show. Coming up, the sober discussion ends and the yelling begins. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
那个来自我们节目制片人之一南希·厄普代克的故事。接下来，清醒的讨论结束，叫喊声开始。那一小会儿之后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program for this Memorial Day weekend, The Center For Lessons Learned. We have stories from Iraq, what we've learned, what we did not learn in time. We began our show today talking to people at the Army's Center for Lessons Learned at Fort Leavenworth, Kansas. And the men at the reference desk there say that their most popular item these days is this 79 page booklet called "A Soldiers' Handbook: The First 100 Days." Colonel Steven Maines, who runs the center, says the whole reason for this booklet comes out of something that they found in the research.
这是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们选择一个主题，带给你们关于该主题的各种不同类型的故事。今天在这个阵亡将士纪念日周末的节目是《经验教训中心》。我们有来自伊拉克的故事，关于我们学到了什么，我们没能及时学到什么。我们今天节目开始时与堪萨斯州莱文沃斯堡陆军经验教训中心的人进行了交谈。那里的咨询台的人说，他们目前最受欢迎的项目是这本名为《士兵手册：前100天》的79页小册子。负责管理该中心的史蒂夫·梅恩斯上校说，这本小册子的全部原因来自于他们在研究中发现的东西。
We did some statistical analysis, and showed that the first 100 days is really the most dangerous part of a deployment. Most of the casualties happen in the first 100 days. So based on that, we said let's transfer that information. Things that the guy knows at day 250, let's transfer that information to the soldier before he deploys.
我们做了一些统计分析，显示前100天确实是部署中最危险的部分。大多数伤亡发生在前100天。所以基于此，我们说让我们转移这些信息。人们在第250天知道的事情，让我们在士兵部署前就把这些信息传达给他。
So to figure this out, they surveyed soldiers who were in Iraq. How did they survive? What were the factors that led to their comrades getting killed? And then they put together this handbook. I have one here. One of the biggest things that got people killed in the first 100 days, soldiers told the center, was just complacency; not properly preparing for patrols, losing focus. Going on patrols at the same time every day, or along the same route, or with the same stops, so the enemy would be able to pick up a routine.
所以为了弄清楚这一点，他们调查了伊拉克的士兵。他们是如何生存的？导致他们的战友被杀的因素是什么？然后他们编写了这本手册。我这里有一本。士兵们告诉中心，前100天导致人员伤亡最大的事情之一，就是自满；没有为巡逻做好充分准备，失去专注。每天在同一时间，或沿同一路线，或在同一地点停留进行巡逻，这样敌人就能够掌握规律。
This book reviews all kinds of practical things like what to do if you're ambushed, how to deal with a sniper. There are procedures that were invented in Iraq on what to do if a bomb stops you in the road. They have names like the five to five drill. Here's the five Cs. In fact, fully half of this booklet is about IEDs, improvised explosive devices, with page after page here of different kinds of IEDs. And then they have these photos of detonators, the detonators which include the most mundane, household stuff, like for example, the little push button thing on your key chain that unlocks your car door. Milt Hileman is a senior military analyst. He was the lead analyst for the information in this booklet.
这本书回顾了各种实际的事情，比如如果你被伏击该怎么办，如何应对狙击手。伊拉克发明了一些程序，关于如果炸弹在路上挡住你该怎么办。它们有名字，比如“五到五演习”。这是五个C。事实上，这本小册子的一半都是关于IED，简易爆炸装置，有着一页又一页不同种类的IED。然后他们有这些雷管的照片，雷管包括最平凡的家庭用品，例如，钥匙扣上用来解锁车门的小按钮。米尔特·海尔曼是一名高级军事分析师。他是这份小册子中信息的主要分析师。
One of the things overall that the handbook's trying to impress upon soldiers is this is a very sophisticated enemy, very intent on killing you and killing your buddies. He's a smart guy. He watches what we do. He learns from us, and we got to be just as smart about looking at what he does and learning from what he does.
手册试图给士兵留下深刻印象的事情之一是，这是一个非常老练的敌人，非常一心想要杀死你和你的伙伴。他是一个聪明的人。他观察我们做什么。他从我们身上学习，我们也必须同样聪明地观察他做什么，并从他所做的事情中学习。
Down on page seven, there's a list of be alert for--.
在第七页，有一个要注意的列表——。
Mm-hmm.
嗯嗯。
I should say to our audience that we've agreed to let you vet which of this material we're going to put over the radio.
我应该告诉我们的听众，我们已经同意让你审查这些材料中哪些我们将通过无线电广播。
Yeah.
是的。
One of the things that shows up a couple of times in the book that you tell people to be alert for is people videotaping ordinary activities.
书中出现几次的一件事是你告诉人们要注意拍摄普通活动的人。
Correct.
正确。
Explain that one. Why is that one in there?
解释一下那个。为什么那个在里面？
Information operation is a big tool of the insurgency. And they videotape their successful attacks as a way of propaganda and recruiting. So it takes a cameraman in the right place to observe what's going on.
信息行动是叛乱的一大工具。他们录制他们的成功攻击作为宣传和招募的一种方式。所以这需要一名摄影师在正确的地方观察正在发生的事情。
There's another section in here. If you'd be willing, I'd like to ask you just to read. Go to page 45. These are tips on how to face the injured and dead. Can I just ask you to just read it?
这里有另一个部分。如果你愿意，我想请你读一读。去第45页。这些是如何面对伤亡人员的建议。我可以请你读一下吗？
Let me just read one paragraph here. "You may be struck with combinations of pity, horror, repulsion, and anger at the senselessness or the malice of an event. You may feel guilty for failing to prevent it, or surviving it. These reactions are all normal, part of being human. You may blame yourself or the USA. It hurts. Keep in mind that these feelings are honorable and confirm your humanity. At times, however, you may feel emotionally numb. Whatever you feel, remember that the mission must continue."
让我读一段。“你可能会受到怜悯、恐惧、排斥和愤怒的组合冲击，对事件的无意义或恶意感到愤怒。你可能会因为未能阻止它或幸存下来而感到内疚。这些反应都是正常的，是成为人类的一部分。你可能会责怪自己或美国。这很痛。请记住，这些感受是光荣的，证实了你的人性。然而，有时你可能会感到情绪麻木。无论你感觉如何，记住任务必须继续。”
And then there's a series of tips. You have 17 tips here that you say can help you do the mission and live with the memories without being haunted by them. And they include very practical things like number eight, keep humor alive, even graveyard humor, with buddies who understand it.
然后是一系列建议。你有17个建议，你说可以帮助你执行任务并与记忆共存，而不被它们困扰。其中包括非常实际的事情，比如第八点，保持幽默感，甚至是坟墓幽默，与理解它的伙伴们一起。
Right.
正确。
But don't get too gross or too personal.
但不要太恶心或太个人化。
Right.
正确。
Number 16, don't be disheartened by horrible dreams, feeling tense or intrusive memories. These are normal. And it's better to have them now than to suppress them. Don't keep them hidden. Share them with your buddies.
第16点，不要被可怕的梦、紧张感或侵入性记忆所气馁。这些都是正常的。现在有它们总比压抑它们要好。不要把它们藏起来。与你的伙伴分享它们。
Right. We're trying to give the soldiers the tools to say hey, I'm OK. These are natural feelings. Get it off my chest, and then I can focus on the mission the next day.
正确。我们试图给士兵们工具说嘿，我很好。这些是自然的感受。把它从我胸中释放出来，然后我就可以在第二天专注于任务。
Milt Hileman. So if all of that is what the military is thinking about when it comes to this war, what  do we civilians mostly think about? Well, we have one answer anyway now, in act two of our show, on the civilian perspective. Act two, Am Not. Are Too. Am Not. Are Too. The journalist George Packer, who reports from Iraq and who wrote the book Assassin's Gate said in an interview recently, when he was back in the United States, that while Iraqis tend to get stuck arguing and refighting old historical battles, there is an American version of that too, where we seem condemned to keep reliving the debates from before the Iraq War over whether to go to war, because they never really happened the right way the first time, out in the open, in the sunlight, which I think is true.
米尔特·海尔曼。所以如果所有这些都是军方在谈到这场战争时的想法，我们平民主要在想什么？好吧，我们现在有一个答案了，在我们节目的第二幕，关于平民的观点。第二幕，不是。是。不是。是。报道伊拉克并撰写了《刺客之门》一书的记者乔治·帕克最近在回到美国的一次采访中说，虽然伊拉克人倾向于陷入争论和重打历史旧仗，但美国也有一个版本，我们似乎注定要不断重温伊拉克战争前的辩论，关于是否参战，因为它们从来没有第一次在阳光下以正确的方式发生，我认为这是真的。
In Salt Lake City, they recently reargued that argument over the war. It was a good place for it, actually, because Salt Lake City is like the Austin, Texas of Utah, the one liberal city in the state. But because the conservatives are more conservative in Utah, it seems like the liberals are more fiercely liberal. And each of those sides brought a champion, so it was kind of like a superfight of the two sides.
在盐湖城，他们最近重议了关于战争的辩论。实际上，这是一个好地方，因为盐湖城就像犹他州的德克萨斯州奥斯汀，是该州唯一的自由派城市。但因为犹他州的保守派更保守，所以自由派似乎更激烈。双方都带来了拥护者，所以有点像双方的超级决斗。
On the left, you had the liberal mayor of Salt Lake City, Rocky Anderson, who's traveled around the country calling for President Bush's impeachment. And on the right, one of the icons of conservative talk radio-- and TV for that matter-- Mr. Sean Hannity. One of our regular contributors, Scott Carrier, lives in Salt Lake. And he was there too, sitting way in the back on the lower level.
在左派，你有盐湖城市长、自由派洛基·安德森，他到处旅行呼吁弹劾布什总统。在右派，保守派谈话广播（实际上也是电视）的偶像之一——肖恩·汉尼提先生。我们的定期撰稿人之一，斯科特·卡里尔，住在盐湖城。他也去了，坐在底层后面的位置。
It was in the air, walking into the theater. Truth be told, we don't like each other very much, us and them. We can be surprisingly civil in the grocery store, or even on the road. But inside the theater, our contempt for each other was naked and exposed. Both sides had come for blood.
走进剧院时，空气中弥漫着这种气氛。老实说，我们不太喜欢彼此，我们和他们。我们在杂货店甚至路上可能会表现得惊人的文明。但在剧院里，我们对彼此的蔑视是赤裸裸的。双方都是来见血的。
Good evening ladies and gentlemen. On behalf of the Associated Students of the University of Utah, we would like to welcome you to our campus.
大家晚上好。代表犹他大学的学生会，欢迎各位来到我们的校园。
The place was sold out and the seating was mixed, so Hannity supporters were sitting shoulder to shoulder with Rocky supporters, and everyone was checking out their surroundings, trying to read hairstyles and body posture. Who is us, and who is them?
地方坐满了，座位是混合的，所以汉尼提的支持者与洛基的支持者肩并肩坐着，每个人都在观察周围的环境，试图通过发型和身体姿势来阅读。谁是我们，谁是他们？
And now, the mayor of Salt Lake City, Utah, Mr. Rocky Anderson. [CHEERS AND BOOS]
现在，盐湖城市长，洛基·安德森先生。[欢呼和嘘声]
Suddenly, it was like, at last, it's on. There was a half minute of cheering, followed by a half minute of booing, and nothing had happened yet. [CHANTING - "ROCKY, ROCKY"]
突然间，就像，终于开始了。有半分钟的欢呼，接着是半分钟的嘘声，而什么还没发生。[高呼——“洛基，洛基”]
All right, there will be a time for that.
好了，会有那个时间的。
It is now my great privilege, please join us in welcoming national television and radio host, Mr. Sean Hannity. [CHEERS AND BOOS]
现在是我的荣幸，请加入我们欢迎全国电视和广播主持人，肖恩·汉尼提先生。[欢呼和嘘声]
I looked around at all the Hannity people and started to count. So on my right, there were two married couples, mid-30's, maybe friends who had left their kids with the same babysitter, clapping and cheering for Hannity. And behind, to my left, were five lesbians, like a rugby team, shouting, Rocky, Rocky. It seemed the two sides were about even, and that everyone had gone equally crazy. Rocky went first. He had 30 minutes to lay out his argument.
我环顾四周所有的汉尼提支持者，开始数数。在我右边，有两对已婚夫妇，30多岁，可能是把孩子留给同一个保姆的朋友，为汉尼提鼓掌欢呼。在我后面左边，有五个女同性恋，就像一个橄榄球队，大喊着，洛基，洛基。双方似乎势均力敌，而且每个人都同样疯狂了。洛基先上场。他有30分钟来陈述他的论点。
We are in the midst of a tragic, disastrous, illegal war of aggression, into which this nation was led by a disastrous presidency.
我们正处于一场悲剧性、灾难性、非法的侵略战争之中，这个国家被一个灾难性的总统领导进入了这场战争。
Rocky's a civil litigator by training and profession, so his strategy was, present the evidence. And he had a lot of it. He showed quotes from intelligence reports, and played video of speeches all up on the big screen with a PowerPoint presentation, like President Bush from 2002, speaking about Iraq.
洛基是受过训练和职业的民事诉讼律师，所以他的策略是，出示证据。他有很多证据。他展示了情报报告中的引语，并在大屏幕上播放了演讲的视频，配有PowerPoint演示文稿，就像2002年布什总统谈论伊拉克一样。
It possesses and produces chemical and biological weapons. It is seeking nuclear weapons. If we know Saddam Hussein has dangerous weapons today-- and we do-- does it make any sense for the world to wait to confront him as he grows even stronger, and develops even more dangerous weapons?
它拥有并生产化学和生物武器。它正在寻求核武器。如果我们知道萨达姆·侯赛因今天有危险武器——我们确实知道——那么在世界等待面对他变得更强大、发展出更危险的武器时，这有意义吗？
Here's Rocky.
这是洛基。
We were deceived. President Bush had no basis whatsoever for making those categorical statements. Because the Bush administration was not acting in self defense. The tragic invasion and occupation of Iraq has been utterly illegal. It constitutes a crime against peace, the same crime for which people were convicted at the Nuremberg Trial. Those costs of the war to the Iraqi people have been massive and tragic. The US invasion and occupation of Iraq has no doubt been the best terrorist recruiting tool Bin Laden could ever have hoped for. [APPLAUSE] Given the scale, frequency, and moral depravity of these outrages, President Bush must be held to account through impeachment and removal from office. If we do not call for accountability, we are complicit. [APPLAUSE]
我们被欺骗了。布什总统没有任何基础做出那些绝对的声明。因为布什政府不是在进行自卫。悲剧性的伊拉克入侵和占领是完全非法的。它构成了反和平罪，这是与纽伦堡审判中人们被定罪的同样的罪行。战争给伊拉克人民带来的代价是巨大和悲剧性的。美国的伊拉克入侵和占领无疑是本·拉登所能希望的最好的恐怖分子招募工具。[掌声] 鉴于这些暴行的规模、频率和道德堕落，必须通过弹劾和免职让布什总统负责。如果我们不要求问责，我们就是同谋。[掌声]
Let me explain something. Utah is about 2/3 Mormon, except for right here in the city of their most holy temple, where they're actually in the minority. Rocky was born into a prominent Mormon family, but as a teenager, he crossed over and began to fight what he called the culture of obedience-- people blindly following authority. And this is why we elected him as our mayor. It's also the reason we, or at least a lot of us, are so proud of him now. And it's why the rest of the state pretty much hates him.
让我解释一件事。犹他州大约三分之二的人口是摩门教徒，除了就在他们最神圣的寺庙所在城市，那里他们实际上是少数。洛基出生在一个显赫的摩门教家庭，但作为一名青少年，他跨界并开始对抗他所谓的服从文化——人们盲目地追随权威。这就是为什么我们选他为市长。这也是为什么我们，或者至少我们中的许多人，现在为他感到如此自豪的原因。这也是为什么该州的其他地区非常讨厌他。
After Rocky, Hannity had his 30 minutes.
洛基之后，汉尼提有30分钟时间。
We've got a lot of ground to cover. I want to thank the mayor for being here, taking time, especially out of his busy protesting schedule. I know he's been going around the country on his I hate George Bush tour, it's nice to see him back in Salt Lake City a few days. I wonder how much the people of Salt Lake City paid for that little PowerPoint presentation from the 1980s.
我们有很多领域要覆盖。我要感谢市长来到这里，抽出时间，特别是在他繁忙的抗议日程之外。我知道他一直带着他的“我恨乔治·布什”巡回演出到处走，很高兴看到他回到盐湖城几天。我想知道盐湖城的人民为那个20世纪80年代的PowerPoint演示文稿付了多少钱。
Hannity didn't talk about the things Rocky had said, whether we were lied to or misled by the President, or whether the invasion of Iraq was a criminal act. Instead, he attacked.
汉尼提没有谈论洛基所说的事情，关于我们是否被总统欺骗或误导，或者伊拉克的入侵是否是一种刑事行为。相反，他进行了攻击。
Did you, in all this talk about impeaching the president, all the platitudes, did you hear any solutions on how we're going to win the war on terror against people that want to destroy our cities? Did you hear anything about how to help our president win a war after one of the worst attacks in American history? Did you hear any praise for these brave men and women that, as we speak tonight, are in harm's way? Did you hear any talk about any success, how our troops are responsible for liberating 50 million people between Afghanistan and Iraq, women and children and men and women?
在你所有谈论弹劾总统的话语，所有陈词滥调中，你有没有听到任何关于我们如何赢得反恐战争以对抗那些想要摧毁我们城市的人的解决方案？你有没有听到任何关于在历史上最严重的袭击之一后如何帮助我们的总统赢得战争的信息？你有没有听到对这些勇敢的男人和女人的任何赞美，他们今晚正如我们所说的那样，正处于危险之中？你有没有听到任何关于任何成功的讨论，我们的部队如何负责解放了阿富汗和伊拉克之间的5000万人，妇女和儿童以及男人和女人？
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Did you hear any discussion about how we closed rape rooms, and torture chambers, and mass graves tonight? Or did you hear the same, old, predictable I hate George Bush? George lied, George lied, George lied. It is the same thing.
你有没有听到任何关于我们今晚关闭强奸室、酷刑室和乱葬岗的讨论？还是你听到了同样的、旧的、可预测的“我恨乔治·布什”？乔治撒谎了，乔治撒谎了，乔治撒谎了。这是一样的东西。
Hannity's main point, and he said it over and over, was that there was nothing wrong with President Bush wanting to go to war with Iraq. Lots of Democrats wanted it too. He had video to prove it, of John Kerry, Al Gore, Ted Kennedy, and Hillary Clinton.
汉尼提的主要观点，而且他反复说，是布什总统想要对伊拉克开战并没有错。很多民主党人也想要开战。他有视频证明，包括约翰·克里、阿尔·戈尔、泰德·肯尼迪和希拉里·克林顿。
Intelligence reports show that Saddam Hussein has worked to rebuild his chemical and biological weapons stock, his missile delivery capability, and his nuclear program. He has also given aid, comfort, and sanctuary to terrorists, including Al Qaida members.
情报报告显示，萨达姆·侯赛因一直在努力重建他的化学和生物武器库存、导弹运载能力和核计划。他还向恐怖分子提供了援助、安慰和庇护，包括基地组织成员。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
And I will say this, if Rocky Anderson will not be equally intellectually honest and open and criticize the very same people that made the very same arguments, it's not George Bush who should be impeached or removed from office, it's your mayor. Thank you for hearing me out.
我会说这一点，如果洛基·安德森不能同样在智力上诚实和开放，去批评那些提出同样论点的同一个人，那么该被弹劾或免职的不是乔治·布什，而是你的市长。谢谢你们听我说完。
[CHEERS AND BOOS]
[欢呼和嘘声]
After the 30-minute opening statements, the next round was a question and answer period. Rocky got to ask the first question.
在30分钟的开场陈述后，下一轮是问答环节。洛基先提问。
We're to start the clock right now. Mayor Anderson questioning Mr. Hannity.
我们现在开始计时。安德森市长询问汉尼提先生。
We rely upon governmental leaders for our protection, billions of tax dollars--
我们依靠政府领导人进行保护，数十亿税款——
But instead of asking a question, Rocky made a three minute background statement. And this upset even some of his supporters. Finally, Hannity stepped in.
但洛基没有问问题，而是做了一个三分钟的背景陈述。这甚至让他的一些支持者感到不满。最后，汉尼提介入了。
What's the question, mayor? Do you have a question?
问题是什么，市长？你有一个问题吗？
I know you don't want to know what's in the rest this memorandum, but this memorandum that laid out--
我知道你不想知道这份备忘录剩下的部分是什么，但这份规定了——的备忘录。
Then the moderator jumped in, Ken Verdoya from the local public television station.
然后主持人介入了，来自当地公共电视台的肯·维多亚。
Ladies and gentlemen, everyone including Mayor Anderson, this is, by your agreed format, a question and answer period. [APPLAUSE] And so, I've got to call for the question.
女士们、先生们，每个人，包括安德森市长，根据你们商定的格式，这是一个问答环节。[掌声] 所以，我必须要求提问。
So, this memorandum, this brief was given to the President. Mr. Hannity--
所以，这份备忘录，这份简报是给总统的。汉尼提先生——
Rocky wasted a lot of time and energy throwing punches in the air, while Hannity walked the stage, gesturing to the crowd.
洛基浪费了大量的时间和精力在空中挥拳，而汉尼提在舞台上走动，向人群示意。
In all of my research of you, all my research of you Mr. Mayor, you focus on one person: George Bush. I have never heard on the issues of weapons of mass destruction. You have never, in any press I've seen, asked for John Kerry to resign, Hillary Clinton to resign. You admire Joe Biden, you've said in interviews. You've said you admire the former Klansman Robert Byrd. Why won't you, and here's my question, why won't you show intellectual honesty? And if you're going to demand that George Bush be removed from office, what about some of your democratic friends who made the same arguments?
在我对你的所有研究中，我所有对你的研究，市长先生，你关注一个人：乔治·布什。我从未听说过关于大规模杀伤性武器的问题。在任何新闻中，你从未要求约翰·克里辞职、希拉里·克林顿辞职。你崇拜乔·拜登，你在采访中这样说过。你说你崇拜前三K党成员罗伯特·伯德。为什么你不——这就是我的问题——为什么你不表现出智力上的诚实？如果你要要求将乔治·布什从职位上免职，那么你那些提出了同样论点的民主党朋友呢？
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
OK, do I get a chance to respond? I, as everybody here probably knows, you say you've read my speeches, but apparently you haven't gotten through to the end. I think that our Congress is absolutely complicit. Those who voted for this resolution were wrong. But let me tell you--.
好的，我有机会回应吗？我，正如这里的每个人可能知道的那样，你说你读过我的演讲，但显然你没有读到最后。我认为我们的国会绝对是同谋。那些投票支持这项决议的人是错误的。但让我告诉你——。
Too much. It got ugly. Verdoya, the moderator, tried to keep things in line, but there wasn't much he could do.
太多了。情况变得丑陋。主持人维多亚试图保持秩序，但他无能为力。
Opportunity for the question, Mayor.
市长，提问的机会。
He just said something. I want to respond to that. I want to respond.
他刚才说了些什么。我想回应那个。我想回应。
I will let you do that, because I can't stop anybody else. I would throw this watch away, but it was a gift from my wife. [LAUGHTER]
我会让你那样做，因为我不能阻止任何人。我会把这块表扔掉，但这是我妻子送的礼物。[笑声]
I've researched you. I know you are out of town, what 74 days out of the year last year. I know that you have-- [BOOS] Hang on.
我研究过你。我知道你去年不在城里，一年有74天。我知道你有——[嘘声] 等等。
You know, I knew you would do this.
你知道，我知道你会这么做。
Can I finish?
我可以讲完吗？
This is classic--.
这太经典了——。
All right, all right. Gentlemen, OK, right now, we're going to freeze. I want to take a break. I do not want this to go any more personal. I want you to ask a damn question about Iraq, and I want you to answer it. Get to the point, ask the question, find the bottom line, put it out there, and then you respond.
好吧，好吧。先生们，好的，现在，我们要冻结。我想休息一下。我不希望这变得更加个人化。我想让你问一个关于伊拉克的该死的问题，我想让你回答它。切入主题，问问题，找到底线，把它拿出来，然后你回应。
When I asking that question, he divides everybody, liberals, conservatives.
当我问那个问题时，他把每个人都分开了，自由派，保守派。
Now, the question please, Mr. Mayor.
现在，请提问，市长先生。
The question is, let me give the background.
问题是，让我给出背景。
When it was over, I walked home feeling tired, asking myself, what just happened? There was no knockout, no clear decision. Everybody came out thinking their guy had won. Nobody had changed their minds. And then I remembered there were two moments in the debate when everybody felt the same way, like what happens sometimes in a concert or a play. The audience becomes one emotion. It happened the first time when Rocky showed photos of dead Iraqi civilians, including bloody bodies of Iraqi children.
结束后，我走回家，感到很累，问自己，刚才发生了什么？没有击倒，没有明确的决定。每个人出来时都认为自己的人赢了。没有人改变主意。然后我记得在辩论中有两个时刻，每个人都有同样的感受，就像有时在音乐会或戏剧中发生的那样。观众成为了一种情绪。第一次发生时，洛基展示了伊拉克平民死者的照片，包括伊拉克儿童血腥的尸体。
Initially, the audience cried foul. You're hitting below the belt. But as the images continued, the room became quiet. Photos of dead children, time stopped, thinking stopped. All that was left was the feeling, this can't go on. We have to stop doing this. It was like mass nausea.
起初，观众抗议这不公平。你在腰带以下打。但随着图像的继续，房间变得安静。死去的儿童的照片，时间停止了，思维停止了。剩下的一切只是那种感觉，这不能再继续下去了。我们必须停止这样做。这就像集体恶心。
Then the screen showed a government document, and everyone snapped out of it. It went by so quickly, but then it happened again, when Hannity showed documentary footage of dead Kurds, victims of Saddam's nerve gas bombings. Whole families lying dead in the street, little kids, dead children. The room became like a quiet lake. And I thought, this is it. The solution lies here. Forget all the political arguments, and just sit by this lake and try to figure out its name. The moon was nearly full. The city was going to sleep. Train horns spread out across the valley floor, and rolled up the sides of the foothills. We don't like each other very much, us and them. But we have this lake between us.
然后屏幕上显示了一份政府文件，每个人都醒悟了。它过去得很快，但随后它再次发生了，当汉尼提展示了库尔德死者的纪录片镜头，萨达姆神经毒气轰炸的受害者。整个家庭躺在街上，小孩子，死去的孩子。房间变得像一个安静的湖泊。我想，就是这个了。解决方案在于这里。忘记所有的政治争论，只是坐在这个湖边，试图找出它的名字。月亮快圆了。城市正在入睡。火车汽笛声在谷底蔓延，并滚动到山脚。我们不太喜欢彼此，我们和他们。但我们之间有这个湖。
Scott Carrier in Salt Lake City. He's the author of Running After Antelope , and a producer with hearingvoices.com.
盐湖城的斯科特·卡里尔。他是《奔跑在羚羊之后》的作者，也是hearingvoices.com的制片人。
[MUSIC - "NOBODY KNOWS MY NAME" BY RICKIE LEE JONES]
[音乐 - 里基·李·琼斯演唱的《没人知道我的名字》]
Act three, The Lessons of Tomorrow, Today. Earlier in our radio show, we were talking about how lately, Congress has been debating withdrawing from Iraq, and timelines for withdrawal, and benchmarks for withdrawal. And we all just felt like, what happened? It's like suddenly people have staked out positions for and against withdrawing from Iraq, and they're all shouting at each other, and there is this momentum toward withdrawal. And the only question seems to be how soon. Is it going to be super soon or is it only going to be somewhat soon? And it's like the US skipped the part where everybody looks seriously at whether withdrawal is a good idea in the first place, or what would happen in Iraq if we would withdraw.
第三幕，明天的教训，今天。早些时候在我们的广播节目中，我们谈到了最近国会一直在争论从伊拉克撤军、撤军时间表和撤军基准。我们都觉得，发生了什么？就像人们突然为支持或反对从伊拉克撤军建立了阵地，他们都在互相叫喊，而且有这种撤军的动力。唯一的问题似乎是多快。是超级快还是仅仅是快一点点？这就像美国跳过了人们认真看待撤军是否是个好主意，或者如果我们撤军伊拉克会发生什么的那部分。
You know what it's like? It's like we got into the war in Iraq without much of a national debate about realistically what's this war going to mean? What's it going to mean to be in Iraq? And now people are talking about withdrawing, without much serious discussion at all about realistically what it will mean to leave, or why we're leaving. So to get some perspective on all these questions about Iraq that are not being talked about so much, we called Thomas Ricks, a Washington Post reporter, author of the book Fiasco , about the invasion and the early years of the war. I reached him in Baghdad.
你知道这像什么吗？这就像我们进入伊拉克战争时没有进行多少关于这场战争到底意味着什么的国家辩论。在伊拉克意味着什么？而现在人们正在谈论撤军，却没有进行任何关于现实中离开意味着什么，或者我们为什么要离开的认真讨论。所以为了对这些没有被谈论太多的伊拉克问题获得一些视角，我们打电话给托马斯·里克斯，一位《华盛顿邮报》记者，关于入侵和战争早年的著作《惨败》的作者。我在巴格达联系到了他。
Right now here in the States, I feel like we hear two opposite things that will happen if the US leaves. And one is that if we leave, it's going to be terrible and it will be a bloodbath. And then the other thing we hear is that if we withdraw, it will help make things better. That we are part of the problem. That we are preventing the Iraqis from sitting down and working this thing out themselves. Those are two radically different versions of what the future would be. Can I ask you to talk about how do we even think about that? How should we even think about this question?
现在这里在美国，我觉得我们听到了如果美国离开会发生的两件相反的事情。一件是如果我们离开，那将是可怕的，将会是一场大屠杀。然后我们听到的另一件事是如果我们撤军，它将有助于让事情变得更好。我们是问题的一部分。我们在阻止伊拉克人坐下来自己解决这个问题。这些是关于未来将会是什么样的两个截然不同的版本。我可以请你谈谈我们甚至如何思考这个问题吗？我们甚至应该如何思考这个问题？
I think it's a good question. I would add a corollary to it though, which is the debate also presumes that it's a binary situation. Either we get out or we stay big and heavy like we are now. You might be able to get yourself to a situation where you stay in a much smaller way, not as an occupying force, which is what we are really now, but as a small security guarantee for all parties. And that might be one aspect of the discussion of withdrawal, is there's different ways to withdraw. There is a responsible way, perhaps.
我认为这是一个好问题。但我会加上一个必然结果，那就是争论也预设了这是一个二元情况。我们要么出去，要么像现在这样保持庞大和沉重。你也许能让自己进入一种你以小得多的方式留下的情况，不是作为占领军（这就是我们现在真正的情况），而是作为各方的少量安全保障。而这可能是撤军讨论的一个方面，是有不同的撤军方式。也许有一种负责任的方式。
What should we be thinking about in thinking about that?
我们应该考虑什么？
Well, you certainly would be playing a different role. You no longer would be an intervener in the daily life of Iraqis. What would your role be? You probably would have a few thousand American troops training and advising this Iraqi army we created. You probably would have a few more thousand American troops to be available to bail out that Iraqi army, if it got in a big difficult fight, or to rescue the American advisers if they were somehow beleaguered.
嗯，你当然会扮演不同的角色。你将不再是伊拉克人日常生活的干预者。你的角色会是什么？你可能会有几千名美军训练和建议我们创造的这支伊拉克军队。如果伊拉克军队陷入了一场重大困难的战斗，或者如果美国顾问以某种方式被围困，你可能还会有几千名美军来救助他们。
You'd also want a few thousand troops in Baghdad as a security guarantor for the Iraqi government you created. All that probably adds up to somewhere between 30,000 and 50,000 US troops. And the only thing is, this was actually the recommendation made at the Pentagon last fall by a group of smart colonels, who were convened to consider the future strategy for Iraq. They summarized it as three options: go big, go long, go home.
你还希望在巴格达有几千名士兵作为你创造的伊拉克政府的安全担保人。所有这些可能加起来在30,000到50,000名美军之间。唯一的问题是，这实际上是去年秋天五角大楼的一组聪明上校提出的建议，他们被召集起来考虑伊拉克的未来战略。他们将其总结为三个选项：大干一场，长期驻扎，回家。
Go long, meaning have a smaller force, but stay for a longer period of time?
长期驻扎，意味着拥有一支较小的部队，但停留更长的时间？
Exactly. Find a way to get smaller and stay longer.
完全正确。找到一种变小并停留更长的方法。
Let me ask you something very basic, and that is it seems that the only reason to do a kind of mass pullout from our presence in Iraq is if it turns out we are doing not much good for anybody at all. How do we tell when we've gotten to that point?
让我问你一个非常基本的问题，那就是似乎进行某种从我们驻伊拉克存在的大规模撤出，唯一的理由是如果我们发现我们对任何人都没有做多少好事。我们怎么知道我们什么时候达到了那一点？
I think actually the break-point for something like that would probably come out of the American political system. The scenarios you hear here in Iraq from people are things like this: what happens if an Iraqi army unit turns on an American unit and slaughters it? Would the American political system, at that point, simply get us out of there? We don't need this. Or if it becomes very clear that there is a full-blown civil war going on in this country, not just the low level chronic civil war you have now.
我认为实际上这种事情的突破点很可能来自美国政治体系。你在伊拉克从人们那里听到的情景是这样的：如果一支伊拉克军队转向攻击一支美国部队并屠杀它会发生什么？那一刻美国政治体系会简单地让我们离开吗？我们不需要这个。或者如果非常清楚地表明这个国家正在发生一场全面的内战，而不仅仅是你现在拥有的低水平慢性内战。
I have to tell you, it's hard to understand how that version of the civil war would look so terribly different from this version of the civil war from here.
我不得不告诉你，很难理解那个版本的内战看起来会与这里的那个版本的内战有何不同。
It would look and feel very different here in Iraq, I think. This is not a normal country right now, by any means. You've had kind of a soft ethnic cleansing going on, but you haven't had the forced movements of hundreds of thousands of people under fire like you had in Bosnia, for example. It would look very different, I think.
我认为在伊拉克，它看起来和感觉起来会非常不同。现在这里绝不是一个正常的国家。你有一种软性的种族清洗在进行，但你没有像在波斯尼亚那样，在炮火下被迫迁移成千上万的人。我认为看起来会非常不同。
So in thinking about different ways to leave, what should we be thinking about in thinking about that?
所以在思考不同的离开方式时，我们应该考虑什么？
Leaving is problematic. It is actually not-- the most difficult of all military movements is retreat under fire. And leaving would probably would be that. Basically, you have 40% of the US Army's equipment, and 40% of the US Marine Corps' equipment in this country. Literally tens of thousands of Humvees, of trucks, of tanks, and Bradley fighting vehicles, and Stryker fighting vehicles, and all this sort of gear of war, of a high tech war of generators and computers. It would take a long time to get all the Americans out of the country and all the American equipment.
离开是有问题的。它实际上不是——所有军事行动中最困难的是在炮火下撤退。而离开可能就是那样。基本上，你在这个国家拥有美国陆军40%的装备，以及美国海军陆战队40%的装备。确实有成千上万的悍马、卡车、坦克、布雷德利战车、斯特赖克战车，以及所有这种战争装备，高科技战争的发电机和计算机。要把所有的美国人和所有的美国装备撤出该国将需要很长时间。
So you'd have the prospect of long American convoys, thousands of vehicles trailed, or interspersed among them, with thousands of Iraqi refugees. Month upon month of convoys heading from here to Kuwait. It would be daily televised images for months, perhaps also of those convoys being bombed or shot at.
所以你将面临长长的美国车队的前景，数千辆车辆拖曳，或穿插其中，有数千名伊拉克难民。长达数月的车队从这里开往科威特。这将是数月里每日电视播出的图像，或许还有那些车队被轰炸或射击的图像。
Do you think somehow it's connected, the fact that we didn't debate so well how to get into the war, and the fact that we're not debating so well what to do at this stage, and how to withdraw or end or adjust to what to do next in the war?
你是否认为这在某种程度上是相关的，我们没有很好地辩论如何进入这场战争，以及我们没有很好地辩论在这个阶段该做什么，以及如何撤出或结束或调整我们在战争中下一步该做什么？
I think because we didn't have the debate going in, because we didn't have congressional oversight, hearings on things like what our strategy was, what the training program for Iraqis was, how many American troops were involved, how much did it cost, was it effective? The basic questions were never asked about this war. It was only last fall, after the Iraq War had gone on longer than American participation in World War II, that Congress kind of began to awake from its slumbers and ask some of the basic questions. But there's an awful lot of lost time there, and Congress still hasn't held a lot of the basic hearings about this war, how it operates. And I think that's one reason the debate seems both so rudimentary, so lacking in information, and so unable to move forward and consider alternatives, and third ways, and consequences.
我认为因为我们没有进行进入时的辩论，因为我们没有国会监督，对我们战略是什么、对伊拉克的培训计划是什么、涉及多少美军、花费了多少钱、是否有效等事情进行听证会。关于这场战争的基本问题从未被问过。直到去年秋天，伊拉克战争进行了比美国参与二战更长的时间后，国会才开始从沉睡中醒来，问了一些基本问题。但这中间有太多的浪费时间，国会仍然没有对这场战争（它如何运作）举行很多基本听证会。我认为这就是辩论看起来既如此简陋、如此缺乏信息，又如此无法向前推进并考虑替代方案、第三种道路和后果的一个原因。
Right. It's a debate that's built on slogans.
正确。这是一场建立在口号上的辩论。
Yeah.
是的。
And one of the things that is not happening here in the States is people talking about, well, what is our moral obligation to this country that we invaded? Don't we have an obligation to just stay until something gets fixed, until we fix something? Does that idea come up among the soldiers you talk to? Do they talk about our obligation to the Iraqi people?
这里在美国没有发生的事情之一是人们谈论，好吧，我们对这个我们入侵的国家有什么道德义务？难道我们没有义务留下来直到某件事被修复，直到我们修复了某件事吗？这个想法在你谈论的士兵中出现吗？他们谈论我们对伊拉克人民的义务吗？
Not with the front-line grunt. Yeah, in the cool confines of the military planners, yeah, you do have those conversations. And that might be why you see a movement to a different sort of American presence. I've got to tell you, the American military approach here now feels very different to me than it did in 2003, 2004, 2005.
不，对于前线的士兵来说不是。是的，在军事规划者的冷静范围内，是的，你确实有那些对话。这可能就是为什么你看到一种走向不同种类的美国存在的运动。我必须告诉你，现在的美国军事方针在这里与2003年、2004年、2005年相比对我来说感觉非常不同。
Back then, the American military was very focused on killing or capturing the enemy, and treated the Iraqi people basically as the playing field on which the game was played. And there wasn't a lot of looking out for the interest, I think, of the Iraqi people, of saying the paramount thing is to protect the Iraqi population.
那时，美国军方非常专注于杀戮或俘虏敌人，基本上把伊拉克人民当作比赛进行的球场。我认为并没有多少关心伊拉克人民利益的事情，说最重要的事是保护伊拉克人口。
Now they are clearly being told by the American generals here, the troops are being told, your number one priority is protecting the Iraqis. Listen to the Iraqis. Respect the Iraqis. Honor the Iraqis. That's a very different message going out to our troops. And putting US forces out in these small combat outposts does increase the risk to US troops, and you're seeing that with the numbers of troops, the 6, 12, 15 a day you're seeing die right now. You are taking more risk. We're seeing more American troops die in the service of protecting the Iraqi population. So it is possible to change the nature of the American presence.
现在他们显然正在被这里的美国将军们告知，部队正在被告知，你的第一要务是保护伊拉克人。倾听伊拉克人。尊重伊拉克人。尊重伊拉克人。那是一个传递给我们的部队的非常不同的信息。把美军部署在这些小型战斗前哨中确实增加了美军的风险，你正在从士兵数量、你现在每天看到的6、12、15人死亡中看到这一点。你正在承担更多的风险。我们看到更多的美军为保护伊拉克人口而死。所以改变美国存在的性质是可能的。
It was really striking to me.  I was down in the Green Zone today, where the American headquarters is in Baghdad. And I thought man, I used to hate coming into the Green Zone. And the reason I hated it is because it had such an air of unreality to it. It gave me a headache. I would rather be out on the hot, nasty streets of Baghdad than inside the air conditioned hallways of the palace there. Because it was just so wildly irrelevant to what was happening outside the walls of the Green Zone in the real Iraq.
这对我来说真的令人震惊。我今天在绿区，那是美军在巴格达的总部。我想天哪，我过去讨厌进入绿区。我讨厌它的原因是它有一种不真实的气氛。它让我头痛。比起宫殿里空调凉爽的走廊，我更愿意待在巴格达炎热、肮脏的街道上。因为它与绿区墙外真正伊拉克发生的事情简直太不相关了。
I remember getting a little bit surly with an American general about 14 months ago here, it was February '06. And I said, you have no idea what it's like on the streets of Baghdad, do you? Because it was really a pure Hobbesian state at that point. And he said, no, no, it's actually pretty good out there. I said, put on civilian clothes, and see if you can walk one mile anywhere in Baghdad alone. And I said, I guarantee you, you won't. By the end of that mile, you're going to be dead or kidnapped. And he said, I don't believe you. And I thought, these guys are just totally out of touch.
我记得大约14个月前，也就是06年2月，我对一位美国将军变得有点粗鲁。我说，你根本不知道巴格达的街道上是什么样，对吧？因为那在当时确实是一个纯粹的霍布斯状态。他说，不，不，外面其实还不错。我说，穿上平民衣服，看看你是否能独自在巴格达的任何地方走上一英里。我说，我保证，你做不到。在那一英里的尽头，你要么死，要么被绑架。他说，我不相信你。我想，这些家伙根本与现实脱节。
It struck me today, being here in the Green Zone, what the assessments are to the situation, this is the first time I've really heard American officials talk about this in a way that the average Iraqi man on the street could understand and say, yeah, that's right. That's pretty much what's happening here. But it was very sober, very understanding of how many mistakes we've made, how much this has been screwed up by the US government, and what a deep hole they're in. I found the sobriety and the edge of pessimism refreshing.
今天在绿区，让我震惊的是对局势的评估，这是我第一次真正听到美国官员以普通伊拉克人能够理解并说“是的，那是正确的，那基本上就是这里正在发生的事情”的方式谈论这个问题。但这非常清醒，非常理解我们犯了多少错误，美国政府把这件事搞得有多乱，以及他们陷入了多深的坑里。我发现这种清醒和一丝悲观令人耳目一新。
I have to say, that sounds actually sort of hopeful.
我必须说，那听起来实际上有点希望。
Hopeful in the bizarre sense that it's a different crew in here now. The problem is, and the huge question is, is it simply too little, too late?
在奇怪的意义上充满希望，因为这里现在是另一套人马。问题是，巨大的问题是，它是否仅仅是太少，太晚了？
Thomas Ricks in Baghdad. A new paperback edition of his book Fiasco: The American Military Adventure in Iraq comes out in July, with a new afterword discussing some of these questions about what now.
巴格达的托马斯·里克斯。他的著作《惨败：伊拉克的美国军事冒险》的平装新版将于7月出版，其中有一篇新的后记，讨论了关于现在该做什么的一些问题。
Our program was produced today by Nancy Updaike and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Jane Feltes, Sarah Koenig, Lisa Pollack, and Alisa Shipp. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help from Seth Lind and Tommy Andres. Music help from Jessica Hopper, web help from Sho Jou Yung. Special thanks today to Steve Cashket, Dan Ephron, Andrew Metz, Haider Hamza, Kiki Munchy, and Brian Sargent. Our website, www.thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. Support also comes from audible.com, where you can download audio books, magazines, newspapers, and radio shows, including archives from the last 10 years of this show, audible.com/thisamericanlife.
我们的节目今天由南希·厄普代克和我本人制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格、简·费尔特斯、莎拉·柯尼格、丽莎·波拉克和艾丽莎·希普参与。我们的资深制片人是朱莉·斯奈德。制作协助来自塞思·林德和汤米·安德烈斯。音乐协助来自杰西卡·霍珀，网页协助来自庄祥（Sho Jou Yung）。今天特别感谢史蒂夫·卡什凯特、丹·埃夫隆、安德鲁·梅茨、海德·哈姆扎、奇奇·曼奇和布莱恩·萨金特。我们的网站，www.thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台分发。支持也来自audible.com，在那里你可以下载有声读物、杂志、报纸和广播节目，包括该节目过去10年的档案，audible.com/thisamericanlife。
WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss Torey Malatia, who says we are not using his real talents.
我们的节目由我们的老板托里·马拉蒂亚进行WBEZ管理监督，他说我们没有利用他的真正才华。
You know, you live your whole life learning how to dominate an enemy and all that kind of stuff. Who likes to be in charge of ensuring that diapers are available?
你知道，你生活了一辈子学习如何统治敌人以及所有这类事情。谁喜欢负责确保提供尿布？
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。